in late May three months after the U.S
imposed sanctions on Russian oil
gasoline made from Russian crude was
delivered to this terminal in New Jersey
it was later distributed to gas stations
across the East Coast
it came from this refinery in Italy
owned by Russian oil giant Luke oil
that's because of a U.S sanctions
loophole that allows banned Russian
crude to be refined in a country outside
of Russia and sent to the U.S
we tracked ships pieced together months
of commodity data shipping documents and
satellite imagery to reveal how Russia's
second largest oil and gas company Luke
oil is sending Russian oil refined in
Italy to companies like Exxon in the
United States without violating
sanctions
our investigation shows that Luke oil's
isab refinery in Syracuse Sicily
represents one of the most extreme
examples of this loophole the vast
majority of the crude for this Refinery
comes from Russia it's then refined in
Sicily
after which it's considered Italian
thanks to a long-standing industry
practice that allows the origin of oil
to change based on where it's refined
the U.S launched sanctions against
Russia as punishment for invading
Ukraine in late February Banning Imports
of Russian oil and oil products as well
as blacklisting Russian oligarchs and
companies the U.S says are close to
President Putin
unlike Russia's largest state-owned oil
and gas company rosnaft Luke oil was not
sanctioned
Luke oil still has a presence in the U.S
and distributes oil products to 11
states according to the company's
website
the only reason it can sell Russian oil
into the U.S is because it stops at the
refinery in Sicily on its way here
Luke oil's refinery in Sicily is the
second largest in Italy and the fifth
largest in Europe
before the war it brought in and Blended
crude oil from at least 15 different
countries with an average of 30 percent
coming from Russia now the overwhelming
majority of it comes from Russia because
European Banks stopped lending money to
the isab refinery after Russia invaded
Ukraine
as a result the Lukoil Refinery was no
longer able to buy crude from other
countries
since April as much as 93 percent of its
feedstock is pure Russian crude
the rest is a Russian Kazakh Blend or
Kazakh according to data from commodity
tracking firm vortexa
all of the crude came from Russian ports
with the most coming from primorsk we
see a shipment loading there in this
satellite image from late March the
vessel here is the SCF baltica a tanker
belonging to Russia's largest
state-owned Shipping Company a company
sanctioned by the U.S
self conflict did not respond to a
request for comment we see the same ship
again a few weeks later delivering that
oil to the refinery in Sicily
it's this crucial stop that eventually
allows Luke oil to sell this oil as
gasoline and other products to the U.S
a spokeswoman for the U.S department of
the treasury which administers and
enforces sanctions declined to comment
but U.S sanctions State an exception for
any Russian origin good that has been
substantially transformed into a
foreign-made product
in general substantial transformation
means that the oil has been changed
through processing or manufacturing such
as refining
refining is a process in which crude is
heated and distilled
while this process technically
transforms the crude into a different
product if the same raw ingredients used
in Luke oil's Sicily Refinery were
brought to the U.S it would be a
violation of sanctions
the refinery exported almost 5 million
barrels of oil products to the us since
March of this year roughly 2.5 million
of those barrels were gasoline
according to the American petroleum
Institute that's enough to fill about 7
million automobile gas tanks
we traced shipments delivered to at
least seven different buyers in at least
13 different locations
some of this was gasoline while we can
see where it was delivered shipping data
doesn't always identify the buyer
data shows fuel oil and gasoline were
purchased by Exxon and oil trading
companies such as lukoil's own trading
arm latasca
the most oil products sent from Luke oil
Sicily to the us since March went to
exxon's terminal in Baytown Texas just
outside Houston
nearby a terminal owned by Magellan
Midstream Partners a company that
transports and distributes oil products
received the largest amount of gasoline
a spokesperson for Magellan said
although they received the shipment they
were not the buyer and shipping data
does not list one
another gasoline shipment over 300 000
barrels arrived at this terminal in New
Jersey
shipping data indicates the receiver for
that delivery was also Exxon
a spokeswoman from Exxon said Exxon
Mobil is complying with all sanctions
and the deliveries it received are
certified products of Italian origin
Luke oil did not respond to multiple
requests for comment
though shipments like these from Luke
oil Sicily Refinery may represent only a
fraction of U.S oil imports they reveal
how difficult it is to track and
eliminate Russian oil in the U.S supply
chain the local refinery in Sicily will
be forced to stop importing Russian
crude and may have to close when
European sanctions Banning it come into
effect on December 5th
in the meantime at a number of gas
stations across the U.S Americans are
filling up their vehicles paying for
fuel that in part adds to Russia's
profits
foreign